こんにちははじめしゃちょーですえー動画
のタイトルにもある通り全く
釣りではございません私明日
手術を受けていきます
はいこれ拍手ですでどこの手術かと言い
ますともう簡潔に言わせていただきます
手です手の手術を明日ちょっとしていき
ますどこがおかしいか分かりますかはい
ちょっと見てみてどっちの手かもまだ言わ
ないから
気づくかな
気づく人いますか
どこがおかしいかわかりますこれとか結構
わかりやすい気がしますねはい気づきまし
たでしょうかこっちの手のここねはい
ボコってこれできてるでしょこれですね
こっちの手にはないんですよドカーンて
ここめっちゃ得してるんですよでこっち側
では全然そういうのなくてもほんとこっち
だけが
異常にドカーンて出てますはいこれ何かと
言いますとガングリオンというものですね
実は結構前にもガングリオンの動画を出し
たんですけども
バッチリ再発しまして相当でかくなって
再発してしまいましてビビらないもうね
皮膚も伸びちゃってんじゃないかぐらい
ここ突っ張っててあのーかなりですね俺
個人としては気にしててであの手術じゃ
なくてもなんとかする方法ってのがあって
何が起きてるかって言うと何か溜まってる
んですってこう風船みたいなのに風船
みたいなのができててその中に何かが
溜まっててそれをこう注射器とかでブサっ
てさして抜くとなくなるんですけども
めっちゃ痛くてそれが
[音楽]
注射がめっちゃ痛くてちょっとグロいの
苦手だなって人はちょっと見れないかも
しれないですけどもこれを実際注射器で
こうブスってさして何が入ってるか中身
吸って出した動画があるのでよかったら
ご覧くださいごめんなさいちょっとだけ
針を指してるんで血が滲んでるかもしれ
ないんですけどもちょっと苦手な方は見
ないでくださいこの中でこんなのが詰まっ
てますどうぞ
お願いします
[音楽]
これがガングリオン
ここに
はいすごくないもう
血とかじゃなくてジェルすごい量のジェル
がここ溜まってて実は俺このガングリオン
なくすためにその
注射針さして抜いてもらうのをもう34回
実はやってまして一時的には小さくなるん
ですけれどもなんかもう癖がついてて何回
抜いても何回抜いても一生ここボッて腫れ
てくるんですよで毎回そのボコなるたびに
バカブっとい針をぶっさしてジェルを抜き
に行くのがちょっともう苦痛すぎて
めちゃくちゃ痛いのとやっぱり僕その
YouTuberというかうつる仕事でし
て手元を移したりだとかよくカードゲーム
とかもするんでカードの開封とかにさ
やっぱボコってなってるとみんなはそんな
気にしないと言うかもしれないんですけど
俺的にはすごい気になっててこれはなんか
もう注射で抜いてもらって通うのも痛いし
辛いしなんとかしたいなと思って明日
ガングリオンの摘出の手術をしてくること
になりましたなんか自然になくなることも
あるらしいんですけども
そんな気がしなくてずっとあるんですよ
なんか別に気にしなくてもいいよとは思う
かもしれないんですけどもなんか最近痛く
て曲げると痛いですよ突っ張って割と
なんか腕の関節とかで負荷もかかってる
ような気がするのでちょっと早々に
摘出手術をしたいなと思ってもうだいぶ
12ヶ月前に実はもう最初の問診というか
検査受けに行ってきました
例えばこっち側の天井から関節の中と
落ち込んで出てるかなと思ってでその深さ
まあ多分表面でいいと思うんですけど
そこのところをちょっと確認
させますじゃあこれからMRIと言います
けどいいですかはい大丈夫です
OKです人生行ってきます
これが不良です
2つ2つ
ですねそしてこれと
ここで
ブドウの房のようにできてるんですよね
そこのところ持ってきちゃうんで基本的に
は大丈夫
是非よろしくお願いしますやりますか
ちょっと考えさせてください初めてね
MRI検査っていうのやったわなんか色々
検査して一応手術ができるっていうことで
なんかねひょっとしたら全身麻酔する可能
性とかもあって1日病院で入院する可能性
もあったんですけどもこの場所的には全然
局所麻酔で行けるらしいということなので
風船の中身をジルを抜くんじゃなくて風船
ごとバシって切って抜き取るっていう手術
をしてきます
ちょっと怖いですやっぱ手首なんでどう
しようかなんか神経に触ったりしたら怖い
じゃん
おちゃらけてますけど結構怖いんですけど
ちょっと明日はこの右の手首のこれにケリ
をつけておこうかなと思います
怖いですけど明日行ってきます
[音楽]
はいえー手術当日です今も病院の目の前に
います朝8時半いやーなんかそんな
大掛かりな手術ではないとは思うんです
けども結局ミスト見れるって言うだけで
めっちゃ怖いですねこれがなくなるって
思うと全然安いもんですあー
怖い行ってきますよ
怖いですねそういうアイドルじゃないです
か感染症になってもごめんねみたいな悪い
みたいなそのなんかちょっとリスクある
よっていうのは仕方ないんですけども
怖いですねミスったらごめんみたいな自分
が書いてありましたガングリオンの摘出
手術ですねガングリオンの摘出術
約2cmの石灰をして
皮下を展開しまくるように到達どういう
ことやっちゃうってことですね最終的には
8CVの
根元を切除します感染のリスクスーパー
セントって書いてありますし通電の神経
血管の損傷がまれにあると場合によっては
知覚障害が起きる可能性があるのと
血栓が起きるんですか
血止まるんですか痛みが残る可能性もある
と
違いますね
はいできました
やばいマジのやつだこれガチャ
この時間は目の前まで迫ってきてます
のでこちらまでここでおかけになってお
待ちください
9時からなので
今多分8時49分あと10分後ぐらいです
ね手首っていうのが怖いですね
使うじゃないですか日常でかなりビビって
何本もあるけど手首って1個しかないねあ
2個あった
[音楽]
除湿室前まで来ました
怖いよ
あれですねインプラントぐらいですね
ガッツリ
めっちゃ入れるとかはないです
[音楽]
実際どうです中のガングリオンとかって見
てみたいですか見てみたいですね皆さん
ここから映せないので
リアクションで反応していただけると
ちょっと麻酔しますはいそれがちょっと
一番痛いと思いますはい頑張ります
頑張ってください
[音楽]
大丈夫ですでもなんかガングリオンの中身
抜いてもらった
あれ痛いですねそれに比べると全然大丈夫
ですそしたら手術より
抜く方が痛いかもしれないですね始まっ
てるんかな全く感覚ないからわかんないん
ですよ俺の体は何かが伸びてる痛みはない
けど手首の
繊維って言うんですかなんか伸びてる感覚
がすごい
怖い
[音楽]
再発だけはどうか
大丈夫です
[音楽]
結構引っ張られる感じがありますね
県とか見てみます
県ですかちょっと見てみたいです
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばい先生
[音楽]
結構人の
体の中って白いんですよ
血が止まってると血が止まってると白いん
ですね
穴空いてた
ありがとうございますはいというわけで
無事終了して帰ってきました
ただいまおそらく成功だと思いますはい
ボコってなってるのがなくなっちゃったね
ただ
麻酔が切れてから
めっちゃくちゃ痛くて今痛み止め飲んで
なんとか大丈夫なんですけども
マジで痛いなんかもう手首の内部がなんか
もうズキズキズキズキ痛み止めでなんとか
大丈夫なんですけどもなんかガングリオン
てポコってなってるとこスッて取るだけ
でしょって思ってたんですけど結構深い
場所からガングリオンで発生しててなんか
1cm以上深いってお医者さんは言って
ましたね剣をこうどかしてそっから
引っ張り出して根元を切るっていうので
かなり深いところでの切除手術だったので
見た目に反してしっかり手術でしたもう何
年かも戦ってきたんでガングリオンとは
なんか僕は手首だったんですけども人に
よっては他の場所にもできたりなんか場所
によっては痛みだったりしびれが出る可能
性があります見た目ももちろん気になり
ますけどもしっかり切除してなくすって
いうのが一番大事なのかもしれないです
いや怖かった初めて俺自分の手首の中見た
もんはい無事に手術が終わったっていう
動画でしたこれにてガングリオン
完結
[音楽]